aumenta la preocupación internacional
frente a un posible desastre nuclear él
oye a catalogó la situación en la planta
nuclear de sap orilla como insostenible
tras publicar su tan esperado informe
sobre los riesgos en la central luego de
que un equipo de expertos de la agencia
nuclear de la onu visitará la zona los
primeros días de septiembre rafael
grossi director general del organismo
expresó su preocupación frente al
consejo permanente de seguridad de la
onu físico attack wing and winding de
los ataques físicos que estas
instalaciones han recibido de los cuales
yo mismo puede evaluar and that i'm your
personal y si han haces conjunto con mis
expertos es simplemente inaceptable
simple
le advierto que están jugando con fuego
y algo demasiado catastrófico podría
ocurrir kate place el informe de 52
páginas presentó 7 recomendaciones para
la planta nuclear de sap orilla entre
las más destacadas se encuentran el
pedido de la creación de una zona de
seguridad y un acuerdo entre las partes
para que se detengan los bombardeos el
organismo también expresó su
preocupación por la presencia de
material y personal militar ruso el
involucramiento de funcionarios rusos
que interfieren en la operación de la
planta y el deterioro de los equipos así
como la dificultad técnica para su
reparación la planta ubicada en
territorio ucraniano pero ocupada por
las tropas rusas desde los inicios de la
invasión ha sido constante escenario de
intensos bombardeos de los cuales moscú
y kiev se acusan mutuamente
y
hablemos con la verdad cualquier daño a
la planta nuclear más grande de europa
en sap orilla o cualquier otra en
ucrania sea con intención o no se podría
traducir en una tragedia en la región y
mucho más allá todas las medidas
necesarias deben ser tomadas para evitar
tal escenario
el step es más vital con turbo escenario
pero sí informó que dos expertos se
quedarán para mantener una presencia a
largo plazo en el sitio